if I have a vector sitting here in 2d
space we have a standard way to describe
it with coordinates in this case the
vector has coordinates 3/2 which means
going from its tail to its tip involves
moving three units to the right and two
units up now the more linear algebra
oriented way to describe coordinates is
to think of each of these numbers as a
scalar a thing that stretches or
squishes vectors you think of that first
coordinate as scaling I hat the vector
with length 1 pointing to the right
while the second coordinate scales J hat
the vector with length 1 pointing
straight up the tip to tail sum of those
two scaled vectors is what the
coordinates are meant to describe you
can think of these two special vectors
as encapsulating all of the implicit
assumptions of our coordinate system the
fact that the first number indicates
rightward motion that the second one
indicates upward motion exactly how far
a unit of distances all of that is tied
up in the choice of I hat and J hat as
the vectors which are scalar coordinates
are meant to actually scale any way to
translate between vectors and sets of
numbers is called a coordinate system
and the two special vectors I hat and J
hat are called the basis vectors of our
standard coordinate system what I'd like
to talk about here is the idea of using
a different set of basis vectors for
example let's say you have a friend
Jennifer who uses a different set of
basis vectors which I'll call B 1 and B
2 her first basis vector B 1 points up
and to the right a little bit and her
second vector B 2 points left and up now
take another look at that vector that I
showed earlier the one that you and I
would describe using the coordinates 3 2
using our basis vectors I hat and J hat
Jennifer would actually describe this
vector with the coordinates 5/3 and 1/3
what this means is that the particular
way to get to that vector using her two
basis vectors is to scale B 1 by 5/3
scale B 2 by 1/3
then add them both together in a little
bit I'll show you how you could have
figured out those two numbers 5/3 and
1/3
in general whenever Jennifer uses
coordinates to describe a vector she
thinks of her first coordinate as
scaling v1 the second coordinate is
scaling b2 and she adds the results
what she gets will typically be
completely different from the vector
that you and I would think of as having
those coordinates
to be a little more precise about the
setup here her first basis vector v1 is
something that we would describe with
the coordinates 2 1 and her second basis
vector v2 is something that we would
describe as negative 1 1 but it's
important to realize from her
perspective in her system those vectors
have coordinates 1 0 and 0 1 they are
what defined the meaning of the
coordinates 1 0 and 0 1 in her world so
in effect we're speaking different
languages we're all looking at the same
vectors in space but Jennifer uses
different words and numbers to describe
them
let me say a quick word about how I'm
representing things here when I animate
2d space I typically use this square
grid but that grid is just a construct a
way to visualize our coordinate system
and so it depends on our choice of basis
space itself has no intrinsic grid
Jennifer might draw her own grid which
would be an equally made-up construct
meant as nothing more than a visual tool
to help follow the meaning of her
coordinates
her origin though would actually line up
with ours since everybody agrees on what
the coordinates 0 0 should mean it's the
thing that you get when you scale any
vector by 0 but the direction of her
axes and the spacing of her grid lines
will be different depending on her
choice of basis vectors so after all
this is set up a pretty natural question
to ask is how we translate between
coordinate systems
if for example Jennifer describes a
vector with coordinates negative 1/2
what would that be in our coordinate
system how do you translate from her
language to ours well what her
coordinates are saying is that this
vector is negative 1 times B 1 plus 2
times B 2
and from our perspective b1 has
coordinates 2 1 + b2 has coordinates
negative 1 1
so we can actually compute negative 1
times B 1 plus 2 times B 2 as they're
represented in our coordinate system and
working this out
you get a vector with coordinates
negative 4 1
so that's how we would describe the
vector that she thinks of as negative
1/2 this process here of scaling each of
her basis vectors by the corresponding
coordinates of some vector then adding
them together
might feel somewhat familiar its matrix
vector multiplication with a matrix
whose columns represent Jennifer's basis
vectors in our language in fact once you
understand matrix vector multiplication
as applying a certain linear
transformation say by watching what I
view to be the most important video in
this series chapter 3 there's a pretty
intuitive way to think about what's
going on here a matrix whose columns
represent Jennifer's basis vectors can
be thought of as a transformation that
moves our basis vectors I hat and J hat
the things we think of when we say one
zero and zero one two Jennifer's basis
vectors the things she thinks of when
she says one zero and zero one to show
how this works
let's walk through what it would mean to
take the vector that we think of as
having coordinates negative one two and
applying that transformation before the
linear transformation we're thinking of
this vector as a certain linear
combination of our basis vectors
negative one times I hat plus 2 times J
hat and the key feature of a linear
transformation is that the resulting
vector will be that same linear
combination but of the new basis vectors
negative 1 times the place where I hat
lands plus 2 times the place where J hat
lands
so what this matrix does is transform
our misconception of what Jennifer means
into the actual vector that she's
referring to
I remember that when I was first
learning this it always felt kind of
backwards to me geometrically this
matrix transforms our grid into
Jennifer's grid but numerically it's
translating a vector described in her
language to our language
what made it finally click for me was
thinking about how it takes our
misconception of what Jennifer means the
vector we get using the same coordinates
but in our system then it transforms it
into the vector that she really meant
what about going the other way around in
the example I used earlier this video
when I have the vector with coordinates
3 2 in our system how did I compute that
it would have coordinates 5/3 and 1/3 in
Jennifer's system
you start with that change of basis
matrix that translates Jennifer's
language into ours then you take its
inverse
remember the inverse of a transformation
is a new transformation that corresponds
to playing that first one backwards in
practice especially when you're working
in more than two dimensions you'd use a
computer to compute the matrix that
actually represents the said verse in
this case the inverse of the change of
basis matrix that has Jennifer's basis
as its columns ends up working out to
have columns 1/3
negative 1/3 and 1/3 2/3
so for example to see what the vector3
to looks like in Jennifer's system we
multiply this inverse change of basis
matrix by the vector 3 2 which works out
to be 5/3 1/3
so that in a nutshell is how to
translate the description of individual
vectors back and forth between
coordinate systems the matrix whose
columns represent Jennifer's basis
vectors but written in our coordinates
translates vectors from her language
into our language
and the inverse matrix does the opposite
but vectors aren't the only thing that
we describe using coordinates for this
next part it's important that you're all
comfortable representing transformations
with matrices and that you know how
matrix multiplication corresponds to
composing successive transformations
definitely pause and take a look at
chapters 3 & 4 if any of that feels
uneasy
consider some linear transformation like
a 90-degree counterclockwise rotation
when you and I represent this with a
matrix we follow where the basis vectors
I hat and J hat H go I hat ends up at
the spot with coordinates 0 1 and J hat
ends up at the spot with coordinates
negative 1 0 so those coordinates become
the columns of our matrix but this
representation is heavily tied up in our
choice of basis vectors from the fact
that we're following I hat and J hat in
the first place to the fact that we're
recording their landing spots in our own
coordinate system
how would Jennifer describe this same
90-degree rotation of space
you might be tempted to just translate
the columns of our rotation matrix into
Jennifer's language but that's not quite
right those columns represent where our
basis vectors I hat and J hat go but the
matrix that Jennifer wants should
represent where her basis vectors land
and it needs to describe those landing
spots in a her language here's a common
way to think of how this is done
start with any vector written in
Jennifer's language rather than trying
to follow what happens to it in terms of
her language first we're going to
translate it into our language using the
change of basis matrix the one whose
columns represent her basis vectors in
our language this gives us the same
vector but now written in our language
then apply the transformation matrix to
what you get by multiplying it on the
left this tells us where that vector
lands but still in our language so as a
last step apply the inverse change of
basis matrix multiplied on the left as
usual to get the transformed vector but
now in Jennifer's language since we
could do this with any vector written in
her language first applying the change
of basis then the transformation then
the inverse change of basis that
composition of three matrices gives us
the transformation matrix in Jennifer's
language it takes in a vector of her
language and spits out the transformed
version of that vector in her language
for this specific example when
Jennifer's basis vectors look like 2 1
and negative 1 1 in our language and
when the transformation is a 90 degree
rotation the product of these three
matrices if you work through it has
columns 1/3 5/3 and negative 2/3
negative 1/3
so if Jennifer multiplies that matrix by
the coordinates of a vector in her
system it will return the 90 degree
rotated version of that vector expressed
in her coordinate system
in general whenever you see an
expression like a inverse times M times
a it suggests say mathematical sort of
empathy that middle matrix represents a
transformation of some kind as you see
it and the outer two matrices represent
the empathy the shift in perspective and
the full matrix product represents that
same transformation but as someone else
sees it for those of you wondering why
we care about alternate coordinate
systems the next video on eigenvectors
and eigenvalues will give a really
important example of this see you then
[Music]